un ex comandante de la contrarrevolución
y una ex reina de belleza esa es la
nueva fórmula presidencial con la que la
oposición nicaragüense quiere plantarle
cara al mandatario daniel ortega en las
elecciones de noviembre
óscar sobalvarro será el candidato
presidencial de ciudadanos por la
libertad partido del que es
vicepresidente en sus tiempos de guerra
fue comandante en la guerrilla de
derecha resistencia nicaragüense
washington financió para combatir a los
sandinistas estamos convencidos de que
un pueblo unido depositando su voto con
la misma valentía y decisión con el que
reclamando su libertad en las calles es
más fuerte que cualquier voluntad
totalitaria la fórmula vicepresidencial
será berenice quesada la señorita
nicaragua en el reinado de 2017 y de
quien no se conocía su activismo
político hasta ahora
si se puede porque de nosotros depende
el cambio de cada uno de ustedes de cada
una de las personas que me está viendo
en su casa de nosotros depende que
nicaragua cambie estos son algunas de
las últimas cartas políticas del partido
pues de los 7 precandidatos
presidenciales arrestados en nicaragua
en los últimos meses tres se habían
inscrito con la alianza de ciudadanos
por la libertad la mayoría han sido
acusados de ser traidores a la patria en
total 29 opositores han sido arrestados
daniel ortega sigue abriéndose paso de
cara a una posible cuarta reelección
barriendo no sólo con contenedores
políticos sino también con quienes
critican su gestión la asamblea
controlada por los sandinistas canceló
el estatus legal de 24 ongs incluidas 15
que cuestionaron el manejo de la
pandemia por parte del gobierno